dans le même temps l'accord conclu le 22
juillet dernier tient toujours plusieurs
navires ont pu quitter les différents
ports ukrainiens avec à leur bord des
tonnes de céréales bonjour à vous mélina
huet envoyé spécial de france 24 à
odessa mélina vous avez pu vous
entretenir avec le directeur adjoint du
port que vous at il dit sur les
opérations d'acheminement de céréales
vous avez écouté un avion comme vous
l'avez dit des bateaux des cargos sont
partis un depuis le 1er août date du
départ du premier cargo 14 ans déjà
qu'ils ont quitté les trois ports du
grand de dessins dont celui dans lequel
nous nous trouvons actuellement deux ont
quitté les clones losc aujourd'hui sur
les quatorze déjà parti ces deux bateaux
qui ont quitté le port du grand odessa
aujourd'hui sont partis avec quasiment
70 mille tonnes de produits agricoles
l'un vers la turquie et l'autre faire la
corée du sud alors l'adjoint du port
d'odessa nous a expliqué que sa plus
grande crainte aujourd'hui c'est
concernant les 20 millions de tonnes de
céréales qui sont encore en stock soit
dans des silos soit dans des grands
entrepôts et qu'ils ne peuvent pas
rester en stock pendant encore quelques
mois puisque et bien depuis le 24
février et ils sont là ils ne partent
pas 20 millions auxquels vont s'ajouter
20 à 25 millions d'une nouvelle récolte
dans les prochaines semaines donc ses 40
à 45 millions de tonnes de céréales qui
vont devoir être écoulés dans les
prochains mois et même si on retrouve
des cadences de cent navires par mois
par exemple qui quittent les port
d'odessa d'ici à quelques semaines bien
ça nous amène à 2023 c'est une situation
qui n'est évidemment pas satisfaisante
ni pour ce directeur adjoint du port ni
pour les agriculteurs que nous avons
rencontrés notamment vladimir 70 ans qui
habite à une soixantaine de kilomètres
d'odessa et qui est bien nous expliquer
que ce qui est très compliqué c'est pour
les petits agriculteurs ou ceux qui ont
des surfaces intermédiaires lui cultive
par exemple 300 hectares de terres et
bien il n'a pas pu vendre une seule
tonnes de céréales cette année il doit
encore payer ses équipes dans encore
payer certains de ces paysans et doit
payer évidemment les factures mais aussi
le le pétrole l'essence pour pouvoir se
déplacer essayer de vendre s'étonne
qu'ils sont encore là soit de cette
année soit de l'année précédente et il
dit qu'il n'arrivera pas à écouler à
tout ce stock d'ici les prochains mois
lui à un entrepôt d'autres n'ont pas
cette chance et laisse tout simplement
les céréales au soleil et si il y à des
pluies dans les prochains mois et bien
ces céréales vont tout simplement
pourrir alors qu'il ya une grande crise
est bien notamment sur le continent
africain qui attend à ces céréales
depuis plus de cinq mois maintenant ce
qui suscite de grandes inquiétudes
mélina on va maintenant se concentrer
sur la situation à un ré sonne depuis
mars dernier elle est russe contrôle
cette villa du sud de l'ukraine et sur
le plan stratégique il opérera un
changement
oui tout à fait c'est ce qu'on appelle
un basculement des troupes russes qui
pour une grande partie à ses besoins
vont basculer du donbass jusqu'à 600 km
de plus vers le sud alors pour deux
raisons potentielles c'est toujours très
difficile de savoir dans cette guerre de
communication que se livrent à l'udc
l'ukraine et la russie soit pour
empêcher une éventuelle contre offensive
des ukrainiens notamment pour reprendre
et bien raide sonne ou bien soin pour
eux-mêmes prendre les devants et essayer
de récupérer du terrain et de progresser
encore davantage dans ces oblath du sud
il ya plusieurs l'enjeu est notamment la
question des ponts que les ukrainiens
tentent de détruire dont un qui est le
plus stratégie de stratégique pardon
suis d'antonov cas qui a été et bien
pilonné à de nombreuses reprises mais
qui n'est pas totalement détruit et
c'est ce qu'essaie de faire les
ukrainiens pour essayer d'empêcher la
progression de ses forces russes et
ukrainiens qui disent que leurs pertes
quotidiennes ces derniers mois et bien
ont largement baissé qu'elles ont été
divisés par deux et demi voire trois
depuis la début juin des forces armées
qui revendique aussi avoir tué près de
300 soldats russes en 24 heures et qui
donc espère pouvoir opérer cette
contre-offensive dans les prochaines
semaines qui seront critiques et pour
l'ukraine et pour la russie bien entendu
un grand merci à vous et mélina mène une
à huet en direct d'odessa merci
également aux personnes
la bouteille d'eau qui vous accompagnent